encouragé depuis près d'un mois
maintenant Nikka 17 ans suit les
manifestations en Iran son pays
d'origine grâce à son téléphone le
gouvernement ils ont vraiment diminué
l'Internet alors c'est vraiment
difficile pour les gens de partager ça
un mouvement de révolte mené par des
femmes des jeunes comme elle comme
Massara mini morte en détention après
avoir enfin le code vestimentaire elle
est bien d'autres depuis sont devenus le
symbole d'une contestation plus large
contre le régime islamique l'intention
derrière ce mouvement c'est pas juste le
hijab c'est les droits de femmes les
droits de femmes de ce divorcer
de leur mari le droit de femmes de
garder leurs enfants après un divorce
c'est d'ailleurs pour toutes ces raisons
que sa mère Sahar a quitté l'Iran et son
ex-mari j'en voulais pas que ma fille
elle habite dans une même situation même
problème que moi c'est des filles qui
peut pas montrer leur face c'est quand
même une personne qui me ressemble si
j'étais en Iran maintenant je ferai la
même chose que les autres l'imam a
chauffe aussi voudrait être à leur côté
rempli d'espoir malgré la répression
sanglante et les autres mouvements de
soulèvement que déjà connu le pays
l'Iran est un pays
culturel beaucoup plusieurs langues
plusieurs cultures plusieurs ethnies
tout ça le gouvernement à chaque fois
essaye de mettre les uns contre les
autres ils n'ont pas réussi retourné en
arrière et quasiment impossible près
d'un mois après le début des premières
manifestations l'ex-président du
Parlement a critiqué la réaction de
l'État et des mesures violentes contre
les manifestants de sécurité c'est une
manière aussi de rester au pouvoir de la
poudre aux yeux selon cette politologue
je pense qu'au fondamentalement c'est un
système qui est remis en question l'idée
c'est pas d'aller distribuer des miettes
à une population c'est véritablement
apporter une réponse politique sociale
économique culturelle d'un côté vous
avez une population qui lutte pour la
démocratie et vous avez de l'autre côté
un état qui lutte pour sauvegarder ce
privilège s'attaquer au privilège de
l'élite c'est scottawa fait avec de
nouvelles sanctions
le gouvernement Trudeau a ajouté
aujourd'hui 17 personnes et trois
entités aussi au gouvernement islamique
d'Iran pour qu'il sera désormais
interdit d'entrer au pays et de faire
affaire avec des entreprises canadiennes
ici Jacques Audrey Charbonneau
Radio-Canada Montréal